direction maintenant les bords de loire
amboise avec ses célèbres cave le lieu a
érigé la dégustation de vins en art de
vivre
certains professionnels pousse même
l'expérience un peu plus loin entre
projections historique et initiation à
l'oenologie lucas chopin niché sur les
bords de la loire à amboise
le lieu a comme un air de vacances les
anciennes caves duhart désormais
qu'avant bastia ont rouvert ce mercredi
et ont fait peau neuve pour l'occasion
en plus d'une épicerie d'un bistrot le
site comprend de nombreuses nouveautés
comme une salle immersive son et lumière
une façon de valoriser l'ancien avec des
modernes on utilise le moderne et les
nouvelles technologies
bah voilà pour pour mettre en scène
c'est ce lieu historique et donc le lieu
va profiter de tout ça c'est la plage
des cadrans bastia où le bistrot avec
une vue sur loire absolument magnifique
évidemment avec 100% des vins des caves
en bastia et des produits de la région
animation sonore explications des
accords mets et vins et visites guidées
par des sommeliers les caves ans bastien
ont un objectif pédagogique mais aussi
ludique grâce notamment à des supports
olfactif qui représentent les
principales senteurs du vin voilà ça
c'est un fruit
je vous dis parce que c'est fera venir
au cadran bastia pour découvrir mais là
on est sur des fruits blancs ou des
fleurs blanches faire appel à sa mémoire
olfactive
c'est très intéressant et ça permet
surtout à terme en fait de prendre plus
de plaisir sur sa bouteille l'heure les
cavs sont âgés de plus de six siècles
mais les ressources qu'elles contiennent
ont encore de belles années devant elle